حكاية أخرى ، حصل كل كتاب في عالم ترامب
على الضوء الأخضر من محكمة الاستئناف بولاية نيويورك ،
هذه القصة التي كتبها
ابنة أخت الرئيس ، وقد وصفت كثيرًا
ولا يكفي أبدًا كيف خلقت عائلتي
أخطر رجل
في العالم ، فلنستعن ببريان ستيلتر من أجل ماذا  هذا
يعني أنه من الجيد للرئيس
أن يراك عائلته والناخبون يا أخي ، ما
هو الحكم ، ما الذي يعنيه أن هذا
هو الكتاب الأكثر مبيعًا على موقع
أمازون في جميع أنحاء البلاد على
الرغم من أنه لم
يصدر قبل أربعة أسابيع أخرى.  وهذا
بسبب العنوان الذي وصفته للتو ابنة أخت
الرئيس ترامب بالقول إنه
أخطر رجل في العالم ، ذهب روبرت ترامب
إلى المحكمة على ما يبدو نيابة عن
الرئيس في محاولة لإيقاف الكتاب
الأسبوع الماضي وحصل على حكم أولي في محكمة محلية
ولكن الآن هناك محكمة
استئناف قالت إن هذا الكتاب سيمضي قدمًا
ويمكن نشر هذا الكتاب بواسطة Simon &
Schuster وهي شركة النشر
التي تقول إنها طبعت بالفعل عشرة
آلاف النسخ ، لذا على الرغم من أن هذا
الكتاب لن يصدر لأسابيع ، إلا أنه يعد
بالفعل من أكثر الكتب مبيعًا على مستوى البلاد
لأن الجميع يريد أن يعرف ما هي
ماري ترامب التي بالمناسبة هي
أخصائية نفسية مرخصة ماذا ستقول عن
عمها نحن  لا أعرف لبضعة
أسابيع أخرى ، لكن هذه المحكمة الليلة تقول إن
الكتاب يمكن أن يمضي قدمًا ويمكن
إطلاق سراحه
ما الهمس الذي لديه
إقرارات ضريبية لأنها ستكون موقعة
على الكثير من أصول العائلة
ما هو الهمس  صحيح أنها ساعدت
صحيفة نيويورك تايمز في الحصول على الإقرارات الضريبية
منذ عامين
وكان ذلك مجرد غيض من فيض ،
فنحن لا نعرف مدى معرفتها لأننا
لا نعرف مقدار ما تم الكشف
عنها  العمل على هذا الكتاب
سرًا لم يتم الكشف عنه للعالم
حتى تم طرحه على أمازون قبل بضعة
أسابيع ولكن فقط بسبب
عنوان الكتاب والاقتراح
بأنها ستقول الكثير من الأشياء الصادمة
عن الرئيس.  هو بالفعل هو
أفضل الكتب مبيعًا
وقد رأينا الآن مرتين في
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية محاولات لإيقاف ترامب أخبرنا
أولاً أن وزارة العدل
تحاول إيقاف كتاب جون بولتون جيدًا
الذي لم ينجح ،
إنه أكبر كتاب في البلاد في
الوقت الحالي  خرجت لمدة سبعة
أيام والناشرين يخرجون
ويطبعون
المزيد من الكتب والآن هناك هذا الكتاب
لماري ترامب ولكن أعتقد أنه سيكون أكثر
أهمية لأنه أحد
أفراد الأسرة يتحدى الرئيس
وقدراته العقلية لياقته للعمل في
المكتب.  سيكون
ضارًا للغاية بالرئيس ، لقد سمعت
ما قلته قبل الاستراحة. كريس الذي
يعرف ما إذا كان سيغير رأي أي شخص
لا يبدو أن أي شيء يغير
رأي أي شخص هذه الأيام ، لكن كتابًا
بهذا الحجم قد يكون مهمًا
وأنت تتجه  في أغسطس / آب ، تتوجه إلى مؤتمر المجلس
الوطني للحزب الجمهوري ، وتتجه إلى الانتخابات العامة
ويكون لديك فرد
من عائلة الرئيس ينقلب ضده